[Music]
hi
i'm christoph zeskowski and we are in
the environmental science center next
door to the
peabody museum building and we are in
the
birded mammal collections of the peabody
museum
here we actually have cabinets full of
bird skins we have about 70 percent of
all bird species of the world
represented in about 250 000 specimens
and here let's look at uh
what they are like so here we are in the
drawer of uh
rents specifically cactus ren and here
i'm holding a specimen
collected in tucson arizona by david
parsons
on 6 april 1958
so each specimen is a point in time and
space
and there's a description of the
internal anatomy
these are extremely valuable to
scientists and used not only by
scientists but also by artists and
for various studies of genetics and
morphology and the reason we have
multiple specimens of each species is
that
is because to do any statistical
analysis on measurements
you need more than one and you can also
see that there is variation not a single
bird here is identical to the other
we actually need to have serious and if
we
move to some species like house ren
where there are multiple geographic
subspecies you can actually see maybe
that these two are quite different
so this one here is from uh
granada island in the caribbean and this
one here from colombia from santander in
the andes
so the reason for collecting multiple
specimens is to for us to
be able to understand things like
geographic variation and
sexual and seasonal variation in these
birds
so here we are with some additional
examples of specimens from the pivoting
museum collections
so in addition to preserving study skins
we also occasionally preserve the entire
bird
in ethanol and these kind of anatomical
anatomical specimens can be used
for visualizing skeleton and internal
organs using
current technologies like cat scanning
computed tomography occasionally
we also generate specimens of skeletons
so here i have an example this is you
may
guess a flamingo
and in this case the skeleton is
disarticulated
means every bone detached and
available for making measurements
and photograph individually
in addition for the exhibits we
sometimes prepare
skeletons that are articulated and in
this
case here there is a great oak skeleton
put together anatomically correctly
and besides these
there's a big collection of nests and
eggs
so here's an example of an egg set
so nicely padded and these are
not your entire eggs but emptied eggs
so you can see these holes in the
equatorial part of the egg
and this simply is an egg shell that is
measurable and can be studied
and nests we have also a
large collection of nests and here is an
example of an oriole nest
uh in suspended from a fork like a
little hammock
and if you maybe zoom in you can
perhaps see that there is a lot of
fishing line embedded into it
there's even a hook dangling
right here so this bird appropriated the
material that found somewhere along the
river and
in addition to all of this we also
preserve tissue samples this is just an
empty tube to show you but
uh for every single specimen we collect
these days we preserve a little piece of
muscle tissue
or some other tissue and these are all
stored in our
liquid nitrogen vapor frozen
facility and what you see on the
exhibits is just a
tip of the iceberg so here behind me you
have a little example
some examples of mammals and birds that
were at some point in the people the
exhibits but now they're
here in storage waiting for another
opportunity
[Music]
you